[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدين على الكرامه انا طاهر
بركه احييكم
وهذه العربيه 260 الخبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قطر تخص شريطه اول مونديال يقام بالشرق
الاوسط وصخبوا الاستعدادات يتوارى ويفسح
المجال للكره
لم يتبناه احد لكن العقاب الصدر مخلب
السيف التركيا هشو شمل العراق وسوريا
انتقاما لتفجير اسطنبول
وجيا وكيف متفائله ببجعه سوداء قد تعيد
لها القرن
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
تبخر المليرات كشف الحقائق قطاع
التكنولوجيا في ازمه منتصف العمره ورواد
هو بشر وليس خارقين
[موسيقى]
تحت شعار لقاء البشريه انطلقت في قطر
نهائيات كاس العالم للمره الاولى في الشرق
الاوسط وشهد ملعب البيت الواقع على بعد
ستين كيلومترا شمال الدوحه حفله الافتتاح
بحضور 60,000 متفرج
فريق بي تي اس مع عدد من النجوم العالميين
لكنها منتخب قطر اصيب بصدمه في اولى
مبارياته بالمونديال بعد الخساره بهدفين
نظفين امام الاكوادور
فالنسيا هدفي المنتخب القادم من امريكا
الجنوبيه في الدقيقه السادسه عشر من ركله
جزاء وفي الدقيقه الحاديه والثلاثين من
ضربه الراسيه وتلعب قطر ضد السنغال في
المباراه المقبله في المجموعه الاولى يوم
الجمعه بينما تلعب الاكوادور ضد هولندا
الرياضيه ضمن العربيه 360 مع زميله
الى ذلك وجه ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان جميع الوزارات والهيئات
والجهات الحكوميه في المملكه بتقديم اي
دعم اضافي او تسهيلات تحتاج اليها دوله
قطر لمسانده جهودها في استضافه بطوله كاس
العالم لعام 2022 في قطر اوجه الامير محمد
بن سلمان وزير الرياضه الامير عبد العزيز
بن تركي الفيصل بمتابعه هذا الامر
اشعلت تركيا لموقفه على الحدود مع كل من
سوريا والعراق بقصفها الجويه العنيف لتاتي
بوادر الرد على ما يبدو بقصف من مناطق
انتشار القوات الكرديه وقوات النظام على
معبر باب السلامه الحدودي برفع حلب
اخر على الاقل قبل ذلك كانت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه اتهمت القوات التركيه بارتكاب
مذبحه في مناطقها خاصه بحق المدنيين
على القصف التركي مؤكده ان عدوان انقر
سيفشل كما نشدت المجتمع الدولي والدول
الضامنه القيامه بمسؤوليتها لوقف هذا
العدوان
اذا اسبوع مره على اعتداء اسطنبول الذي
راح ضحيته سته قتلى وعشرات الجرحى اتهمت
انقره وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه بالوقوف
خلفه وتوعدت بالرد فكان الرد بعمليه اطلقت
عليها انقره اسم المخلب السيف بدات ليلى
السبت الاحد دمرت خلالها الطائرات الحربيه
89 هدفا وافقه ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه العمليه طالت مناطق واسعه في شمال
العراق وشمال سوريا قنديل
وهاكورك شمال العراق وعين العرب وتل رفعت
والمالكيه شمال سوريا الدفاع التركيه قالت
ان القواعد المستهدفه شملت ملائكه وكهوفا
وانفاقا ومستودعات ذخيره ومقرات ومعسكرات
تدريب تابعه لحزب العمال الكردستاني في
العراق ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في
سوريا
في هذا السياق العمليه التي نفذت ضد اهداف
ارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا منذ
منتصف ليل هذا المساء تم التخطيط لها
بحساسيه
ولحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح
لكن ماذا عن القتلى المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان افاد بوقوع 65 قتيلا وجريحا في
محافظات حلب والحسكه والرقه المرصد اشار
الى ان بين القتل 13 من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قصد اضافه الى الناشط اعلامي
في منطقه جبل في المالكيه وريف الدرباسيه
وريف ابو راسين بينما قتل 12 عنصرا من
قوات النظام السوري الى جانب عنصر من
القوات الكرديه في شمال غرب حلب وشمال غرب
الحسكه وشمال الرقه بالتزامن اصدر جهاز
مكافحه الارهاب في كردستان العراق بيانا
قال فيه ان تركيا نفذت اكثر من 25 عمليه
قصف جوي استهدفت مقرات ومواقع لحمايه
لوحدات حمايه الشعب وحزب العمال
الكردستاني وتم التاكيد على ان
و30 من مسلحين وحدات حمايه الشعب وحزب
العمال الكردستاني قتلوا وجرح عدد اخر منه
او غيرهم اضافه اليهم القصف طالما مناطق
الحسكه وريف حلب والرقه وعين العرب شمال
سوريا وقرى قضاء ماوت وصفح قنديل وجبال
كورك واسيس ومنطقه برادوست شمالا العراق
[موسيقى]
اصرفت تركيا على اتهام حزب العمال ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه بالوقوف خلف تفجير
اسطنبول رغم فيهما اي علاقه لهما بالتفجير
رغم ذلك شنت انقر العمليه
لتنهي ضرباتها التي تسببت بمذبح بحق
المدنيين والصحافيين في المالكيه وفق وصف
المتحدث باسم قسد فرهاد شامي بينما رات
الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا ان
تفجير اسطنبول ما هو الا ذريعه لتبرير
هجوم تركيا على شمال وشرق سوريا الاداره
الذاتيه الكرديه ناشدت المجتمع الدولي
والدول الضامنه للقيام بمسؤولياتها لوقف
ما اسمته العدوان اضافه الى الممارسات لا
انسانيه كافه لتركيا كما جاء في البيع
في المركز لعين العرب كوباني المدينه ذات
الرمزيه الكبيره بالنسبه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه استهداف كوباني المركز ب 14
غار جاء بسبب ان قرار اعتداء اسطنبول
الاسبوع الماضي اتخذ في المدينه بحسب ما
افادت التحقيقات التركيه كوباني كانت اول
من تصدت لتنظيم داعش وخاضت وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه فيها معركه ضده عام 2014
للدفاع عن المدينه وتلقت خلالها للمره
الاولى دعما عسكريا مباشره
كتب المتحدث باسم الوحدات الكرديه نوري
محمد في تغريد ان مدينه كوباني البطله
اوقفت بما داعش وحامه الانسانيه وعلى
المجتمع الدولي ان يدعمها اليوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احد سكان عين العرب تحدث عن حالتي هلا
عنوه خوف بين السكان خصوصا على اطفالهم
الذين يبكون طوال الوقت نتيجه اصوات
الانفجارات القويه بدوره ندى القائد العام
لقصد مظلوم عبدي بالقصف التركي ووصفه
بالعدوان الهمجي اقل في تغريد ان القصف
على مناطقنا الامنه يهدد المنطقه برمتها
وليس لصالح اي طرف
انا قصد تبذل جهدا كي لا تحدث فاجعه كبرى
ولكن ان صارت الحرب سيتاثر الجميع
بنتائجها مهددا كما ذكرنا بالرد على تركيا
بالوقت والمكان المناسب
السيف ليست العمليه التركيه الاولى في
سوريا منذ العام 2016 سنه انقره ثلاثه
عمليات عسكريه استهدفت بشكل اسيا
المقاتلين الاكراد تمكنت انقره خلال لها
بالتعاون مع فصائل سوريا مواليه بالسيطره
على مناطق ح واسعه تركيا هددت مرارا بشنه
هجوم جديد ضد المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا
في وقت سابق من العام الحالي الا ان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لم يحصل
وفق محللين على ضوء اخضر من ايران وروسيا
اللاتيني تمتلكان نفوذا واسعا في سوريا
للقيام بذلك لكن يا طاهر يبدو ان الضوء
اخضر اليوم طبعا ينضم الينا حوله هذا
الموضوع من اربيل الكاتب والباحث السياسي
كفاح محمود اهلا بك سيد كفاح يعني اغلى
بالتحليلات تجزم بانه الان هناك ضوء اخضر
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتركيا
للقيام بهذه العمليه ولكن هناك همم حديث
بانه من قبل الحزب العمال الكردستاني بانه
هذه الضربه التركيه قد تتحول الى غزو
واحتلال تركي هل يمكن للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تقبل بذلك اصلا همم
اردوغان هل يمكن ان ينزلقا الى هذا
المستنقع قبيل الانتخابات التركيه
مساء الخير
يعني مساله الغزو لا اميل لها يعني ممم
ليس من يعني من المعقول ان تقوم تركيا
بحماقه مثل يعني مثل هذه الحماقه بغزو ااه
هذه المنطقه او حتى في همم في كردستان
العراق همم نتذكر جميعا همم حماقات مثل
هذا النوع عملها مثلا الرئيس السابق صدام
حسين في الكويت
ودفع ثمنها باهظا على مستوى الشخصي على
مستوى حزبه على مستوى النظام والدولهمتها
ثم الحماقه الاخرى في روسيا واخرى ما بين
روسيا واخرانيا اعتقد الاتراك يعني كان
رجال دوله ليس من المعقول الذي يستفيد من
تجارب مثل حالتين التجربتين البائستين
عموما
انا اعتقد الامريكان اييي كانوا منذ عده
السنوات يضغطون على الحزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي ان يقطع علاقته بتنظيمات فكك
في قنديل ولكن يبدو انهم فاشلوا وهناك
كثير من من الخبراء يعتقدون بان الامريكان
منحوا هذا الجرين كارد للقوات التركيه
ربما للضغط على على هذه المجموعات في
سوريا لكي تقطع علاقاتها خاصه من
الامريكان يعرفون فكك منظمه ارهابيه همم
مع كثير من بعض الدول الاوروبيه ولذلك
تشعر الولايات المتحده بحرج كبير حينما
تدعم هذه الازرع التي تعلم بانها مع مع
حزب العمال الكردستاني
اعطت الضوء الاخضر ايضا بعدما كانت حجبته
او منعته عن انقره في السابق عندما طلب
اردوغان شان هذه العمليه مثل هذه العم
فالسابق كما ااا نذكر خاصه بعد اجتماعه مع
قاده ايران وروسيا همم ولكن الحديث همم
استاذ كفاح هو عن همم الحديث التركي عن
همم يعني محاربه الارهاب وعادت تركيا
لتقول انه نحن اا نحاول ان نحمي حدودنا من
الارهاب همم ودقت ساعه الحساب لانه هذه
العمليات مثلا الاخيره صدر القرار في
كوباني بالتالي هناك همم امن قومي بالنسبه
الى تركيا يجب على هذه الجماعات اضافه الى
الحكومه السوريه والعراقيه ان همم تبحث
فيهما او ان تبحث فيه فيها
استاذ استاذ عيدك قليلا الى التاريخ ليس
القديم
في حادثه مفتعله في عشيه الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه حينما خانت مجموعه بمحاوله
لاغتيال او رمي طارق عزيز ومجموعته في
زيارتهم لاحدى الجامعات العراقيه في بغداد
واظنها كانت المستنصريه وفي حينها قتل
البعض وجرح همم سيد طارق عزيز
وقتها اكثر ما صدام حسين بان هذه الدماء
لم تذهب سدا ما حصل في اسطنبول ذكرني
حقيقه بهذه الحادثه نفس يعني نفس
التهديدات همم اظن انه حتى الحادثه مفتعله
خاصه اذا ما عرفنا الطاهر والزمينا
العزيزه راويه بانه هناك صراع داخلي بين
ال- ال- بين الفعاليات السياسيه التركيه
وانا امين الى انه العمليه ربما كانت
مخابراتيه او ربما كانت داخليه اكثر من
كونها يعني
علقت على شماعه حزب العمال الكردستاني او
جهه اخرى وهذا السيناريو او المفبرك في
كوباني وفي جاءت من عفرين والى اخره في
البدايه سوقوا بانها كرديه ثم طلع يعني
سوقوا انها صوماليه وعربيه وعموما انا
اعتقد هذا التناقض الرهيب في السياسه
الخارجيه التركيه تذكر معي ايضا في كوباني
حينما ذهبت البيشمركه لتعين المقاتلين في
كوباني لتحريرها من منظمه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه داعش الاتراك سمحوا لقوات الجيش
الملكي القادمه من كردستان العراق عبر
الاعراضها ذهبت الى كوباني لتساعد الثوار
هناك او المدافعين عن كوباني همم ما الذي
اختلف ان ان يتحول المدافعين في كوباني
الذين قاتلوا داعش يتحولون بنظره همم
الخطاب السياسي التركي الى ارهابيين
انا اعتقد هناك اجيندا اكبر من هذا هذه
الاجنده تقع ضمن حلبه الصراع في هذه
المنطقه من الشرق الاوسط ما بين هذه
الاخطاب الاتراك والايرانيين والروس
والامريكان طبعا الحلقات الضعيفه هي
النظام العراقي والنظام السوري
وحتى الاحزاب العامله هناك يعني في همم في
سوريا انا اعتقد يعني مجرد تصريحات ليس
اكثر الاتراك اكرر مره اخرى همم لن
يرتكبوا حماقه عمليه غزو واحتلال كما
فعلوا في هذا الشريط او يوسعوا هذا الشريط
لكنهم سيختفوا
بقبول امريكي وروسي بعمليات القصف سواء
داخل اقليم كردستان او في همم في المناطق
الكرديه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
نحن بكون معكم في العربيه 360
اهلا بكم من جديد في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه
على ضروره الوقف الفوريه
اذا الحرب في اوكرانيا تقترب من طي صفحه
شهرها التاسع والحل يبدو بعيد المنال مع
تمسك بعدم التفاوض مع موسكو الا بنسحبها
الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرزنس كي 7 فكره
اقرار هدنه قصيره مع روسيا وقال انها لن
تؤدي الا الى التفاؤكم الامور اعتبرتك لان
اي هدنه في الوقت الحالي ستمنح روسيا فتره
راحه لاستعاده قوتها وان السلامه الحقيقيه
والدائم لا يمكن تحقيقه الا عبر التدمير
الكامل للقوات الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ليعيدها بذلك ما تحدث عنه قبل
ايام خلال زيارته لمدينه خرسون
[موسيقى]
فوكسنا بكل اراضيه نحترم القانون الدولي
وسياده جميع الدول لكننا هنا نتحدث عن
بلدنا لهذا السبب نقاتل ضد العدوان الروسي
اوكرانيا اكدت ان روسيا لم تتواصل رسميا
معها بشان احتمال عقدي محدثات السلام
قوات الروسيه بالكامل قبل حصول اي مفاوضات
قال مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني اندريما
ان اي محادثات غير مبنيه على سياده
اوكرانيا ووحده اراضيها ضمن حدودها
المعترف بها دوليا لن تكون مقبولا بدوره
اعتبر ميخايله فودالياك مستشار مدير مكتب
الرئيس الاوكراني ان زمامه المبادره
عسكريه بيدي اوكرانيا وان التفاوض في
الظروف الراهنه يعني بشكل او باخر
استسلاما غير مبرر
[موسيقى]
لطاوله المفاوضات وستقدم لنا لن تقترح
السلامه وتحرير اراضينا ببساطه تتوقف
وخلال هذا الوقت ستحسد قواتها وستبحث عن
اسلحه اضافيه كما انها ستبني التحصينات
على طول نهر
الدعواته للتفاوض بدات تظهر بشكل غير
مباشر وتحديدا من الولايات المتحده واكثر
من مره تحدث رئيس الاركان الامريكي
الجنرال مارتملي عن وجوده فرصه محتمله
لبدء محادثات من اجل ايجاد حل سياسي
للنزاع ايضا المتحدث باسمي مجلس الامن
القومي جون كربي اعتبر ان المفاوضات افضل
الحلول الممكنه الا ان الامر يبقى متروكا
للرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي ميرسلنسكي ليحدد
وقت وشكل هذه المفاوضات دون اي ضغط على
اكياس في هذا الشان ومع الحديث عن
المفاوضات بدات تخرج من اكياس توقعات
بقربي نهايه هذه الحرب كيف التفاصيل معك
يا طاهر
الى نهايه الحرب بحلول الربيع المقبل
واستعاده المزيد من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اللي هو قال
ان قوات بلاده قد تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا موديل 2014
بحلول اعياد الميلاد اي في ديسمبر الا ان
الامر سيحتاج بعض الوقت قبل نهايه الحرب
في اوكرانيا كما لم يستبعد هافري لوف
احتماله وقوع ما يعرف بنظريه البجعه
السوداء داخل روسيا اي الاحداث المفاجئه
والتي لا يمكن التنبؤ بها في الاشهر
المقبله في اشاره ربما الى تطور سياسيا
غير متوقع قد يؤثر على الكرملين مباشره
اسبوع
او كان احتمال وقوعها غير وارد على
الاطلاق ينطبقوا هذا على احداث غيرت
العالم مثل الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وايضا في الفتره القريبه جدا
مع التحركات
يفرون الى منطقه همم كرسنودار الروسيه
المجاوره وسط مخاوفه من ان اوكرانيا
ستتحرك قريبا لاستعاده المنطقه قبل ذلك
قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه الجمعه ان
الوحدات الروسيه قامت بحفر خنادق جديده
بالقرب من حدود شبه جزيره القرم كما غرد
قبل اسبوع بن هات جزء القائد العام السابق
لجيش الامريكي في اوروبا قال ان منظومه
الصواريخ هاي مارس ستبدا العمل قريبا من
خرسان ما يعني ان شبه جزيره القرم تقع ضمن
نطاق الصواريخ عبر ايضا عن قناعته بان هذا
يمكن ان يضعف الدفاعات الروسيه بينما يسعى
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد للسيطره على
مدينتي مريوطل ومليتي بول بحلول يناير ثم
تبدا المرحله الحاسمه من الحمله استعاده
شبه جزيره القرم
[موسيقى]
المزيد حول هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس
دكتور
من حيث مجال متابعتك وخبرتك وتخصصك هل
يمكن ان تسقط لنا الكلام الذي تحدث فيه
نائب وزير الدفاع هل يعني هذا منطقي كان
يتحدث بكل ثقه عن نهايه الحرب في الربيع
وربما ابكر من ذلك ايضا السيد فضل وياك
مستشار الرئيس يتحدث عن وجهتين اساسيتين
انا الان هما
ولوجان والبعض يتحدث عن القرم ايضا قريبا
تلك التي لم يكن احد يتوقع انه يمكن ان
تكون في همم يعني جدول اعمال هذه الحرب
على الاقل
يعني اذا ما نظرنا الى خلفيه هذه
التصريحات والى السياق الذي تاتي به اعتقد
ان يمكن فهم الدوافع خلف هذه التصريحات
هناك يعني جهد واضح جدا في الغرب وتحديدا
في كيف الاستثمار هذه اللحظه بعد التطورات
الاخيره في الميدان وخصوصا انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من الضفه الغربيه لانها نهر
النيبر في في مدينه خيرسون هذا هذه
الاجواء مع نوع من الزهو بالانتصارات
العسكريه في مناطق معينه على الجبهه
الغربيه للجيش الاوكراني ادت الى يعني
مزيد من التفاؤل وتوقع ان المبادره اصبحت
بيض بيد القوات الاوكرانيه وان الزخم
السياسي بما يوصف به المجتمع الدولي هو
مؤيد لهذا يعني
معنويات الجيش الاوكراني ولما طالب الجيش
الاوكراني هو طالب كيف في هذه اللحظه هناك
من يريد استثمار هذه الاجواء وهذا المناخ
في الوصول الى نتيجه سياسيه سريعه لكن
المخفي من هذا المشهد وما يختزله هذا
المشهد هو التطورات الاخرى وتحديدا في
الجبهه الغربيه يعني نتحدث عن تحالف
الغربي برمتهم هناك تطورات اكثر تاثيرا
حتى من التطورات العسكريه الميدانيه همم
رئيس الاركان الامريكي حين تحدث عن حين
دعا كياب الى المفاوضات وتحدث عن ضروره
الوصول الى حال سياسي ايضا في سياق كلامه
نفسه قال ان اوكرانيا بقدراتها الحاليه
غير قادره على هزيمه روسيا هزيمه كما
تتوقعها هي وبالتالي هو يعتبر ان هذا سببا
حقيقيا للوصول الى طاوله المفاوضات لكن
الان اذا نظرنا الى الصوره الكامله نجد ان
الموقف بين كلاب وموسكو متابعه جدا الا
اولويات يعني سقف التوقعات عند كل عاصمه
من العاصمتان مختلفه تماما عن بعضها البعض
والمطالب من نهايه الازمه مختلفه ايضا
دكتور محمد يعني الصوره الكامله ولكن غير
التطورات العسك الحاصله على الارض يبدو ان
اكياس على لسان نائب وزير دفاعا تعول على
نظريه البجعه السوداء هل روسيا هي بلد
يمكن ان تحصل فيه هذه النظريه وباي شكل
اولا لا يمكن توقع بجعه سوداء يعني هي
مفهوم النظريه قائم على عدم التوقع وعلى
ان هذا هذا الحدث ياتي مفاجئا من خارج
السياق ويغير الاتجاهات بشكل كامل اعتقد
ان النظريه الاقرب الى يعني التفاعلات هذه
الازمه تنطبق على نظريه اثر الفراشه اكثر
مما تنطبق على البجعه السوداء لانه هناك
تراكم لهذه الاحداث وهناك احداث كانت
صغيره جدا وكبرت لتصبح مؤثره جدا في
المشهد الكامل واتحدث هنا تحديدا عن
التطورات الاقتصاديه في نظام اقتصادي
الدولي وفي ال- يعني ازمه التضخم التي
يعاني منها التحالف الغربي هذا على
المستوى يعني الاقتصادي لكن ايضا على
مستوى التسليح ومستوى يعني الامداد
بالذخيره للميدان وهنا هناك ازمه عند
الجانبين لكن هناك ازمه واضحه اصبحت في
اوكرانيه بسبب استنزاف كميات كبيره من
التسخير ومطالب الدول الاخرى من خارج من
خارج الناتو حتى بتدخل لامداد اوكرانيا
بهذه التقدير الى كل ذلك نعم
لكن تبقى
وقت استفاده من وجود حضرتك زنس
كي لا مفاوضات او محادثات مع روسيا الا
بعد انسحابها من حدودنا المعترف بها دوليا
باي اطار تدعى كلام هذا الرجل هل هو فقط
للدعايه الداخليه لانه فعلا متمسك بموقفه
مع العلم بانه هو مدعوم من الغرب كل يعني
كل قطعه سلاح هي من الغرب نعم
زينسكي يلمسنيه وزخم غربي كبير جدا وصادق
هذا الزخم موجود لايصال الجميع الى طاوله
مفاوضات ومحاوله ختام هذه الحرب باسرع
طريقه ممكنه وبافضل طريقه ممكنه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا والاتحاد الغربي هو يريد
الاستفاده من هذا الزخم ويريد ان يرفع
سقوف بمطالباته لتحقيق هذا الشيء لكن هناك
اجانب الاخر وهنا نتحدث عن عدم امكانيه
العايش في المدن التي تقع فيها الاشتباكات
يعني بعد 10 ايام من الان وحتى الربيع
المقبل هناك استحاله من ناحيه التامين
الطاقه ومن ناحيه وجود المدنيين الاولويه
القصوى اذا ما نريد ان نكون عقلانيين وعن
يكون يعني همم تصرف اكياس منطقيا في هذه
اللحظه هو لاجلاء المدنيين من المناطق
التي لن يكون بالامكان امدادها بالكهرباء
في الاشهر المقبله هذه الاولويه المنطقيه
التصورات الحربيه والتوقعات الحربيه اعتقد
انها لن تكون كبيره جدا في حتى قدوم
الربيع وان كان البعض يتحدث الان عن تجهيز
روسي لهجوم في شهر ديسمبر في اواخر شهر
ديسمبر وهذا امر يعني متعارض مع السياق
الذي تحدثتم به عن توقعات لديكيه بان
تسيطر على القرم وغير ذلك
ونرى ان كان سيغير حقيقه ما يجري على
الميدان دكتور محمد سيف الدين الباحث
العلاقات الدوليه وشان روسي من باريس شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
الانتفاضه او الثوره في ايران كما اسمها
الرئيس الفرنسيه
في القاعده الايديولوجيه للنظام منذ قتل
الشابه مهسا اميني في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر المعطي صفا الايرانيون في طول
البلاد وعرضها ممددين بالقمع المنهج
للحريات والحقوق الذي تمارسه السلطات عبر
اجهزتها من حرس ثوري وبسيج وشرطه اداب
وغيرها صفافا حلله الباحث الفرنسيه
قوي بين الاجيال داخل الحرس الثوري اولا
بين القاعده والضباط الشباب وقاده الاركان
وبين القاده والضباط السابقين المرموقين
الذين اصبحوا الان منتقدين حادين للاوضاع
الحاليه
[موسيقى]
احتفظ القاده السابقون بنفوذ معين من خلال
مدوناتهم والتي تكون احيانا قاسيه جدا او
في وكالاتهم الصحفيه مثل تناك التي اسسها
القائد العام السابق للحرس الثوري محسن
رضائي
في الكفاءه الفنيه للموظفين الامنيين
الحاليين وشرطه الاداب والمراكز المحليه
في البسيج والهيئات المسؤوله عن الرقابه
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه على المستوى المحلي
واصر البعض الاخر على الحاجه الى الحوار
وسرعان من انضم اليهم زعماء دينيون طرحوا
فكره احداث تغيير سياسي جذري في البلاد
القمع الشرس للاحتجاجات بدا في المناطق
النائيه بدءا من سيستان بلوشستان حيث بلغ
عدد القتلى فيها حوالي 3 المتظاهرين بينما
يمثل البلوش الثلاثه بالمئه فقط من سكان
ايران وكذلك في منطقه اذربيجان وفقد صحيفه
الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
لكن لا يبدو ان اصوات التغيير والقاده
تلقى اذان صاغيه لدى المرشد الايراني
بحسب وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه انه رغم
الشرور ستتواصل او ستواصل الامه الايرانيه
المضيئه قدما وشدد على ان هدف ايران هو
ابطال الديمقراطيه الليبراليه تقود
المناطق الكرديه بشكل خاص الانتفاض في
ايران ومنها مدينه مهاد الواقعه شمال غرب
البلاد التي تحمل رمزيه خاصه لماذا لان
مهابات شهدت عام 46 من القرن الماضي نشوء
جمهوريه مهابات الكرديه التي استمرت في
العيش عاما واحدا فقط تعاني المدينه اليوم
قمعا شديدا
وشهدت ليله ساخنه نتيجه الهجوم المكثف
للقوات الامنيه والعسكريه بالاسلحه
الثقيله ضد المحتاجين المحتجون خرج صباح
امس للمشاركه في جنازه كما الاحمد بور
الذي قتل يوم الجمعه برصاص الامن وفوق ذلك
قطعت الكهرباء والانترنت عن المدينه
وتعالت الاصوات المناديه باغاثه الاهالي
بدوره حذر الحزب الديمقراطي والكردي في
بيان من الوضع الخطير في تلك المدينه
منبها الى ان الحرس الثوري يحشد عناصره
للهجوم على المنطقه
[موسيقى]
حصيله القمع حتى الان واثقه وكاله انباء
حقوق الانسان الايرانيه هيرانا بلغت 400
واربعه قتله بينهم ثمانيه وخمسون طفلا
ومراهقا بينما اعتقل 16 الفن
1813 محتجا بينهم
524 طالبا وبحسب الوكاله شاركت 150 مدينه
و 140 جامعه على مستوى البلاد في
الاحتجاجات المستمره وتم تشكيل الف
وثمانيه تجمعات في المدن والجامعات حتى
الان
راكان
[موسيقى]
في العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد
التي رافقتها يقول موقع اتلانتيك ان شركات
التكنولوجيا اصيبت بالصدمه بسبب التضخم في
فتره ما بعد الجائحه كورونا وارتفاع اسعار
الفائده هذه الازمه فتحت الباب واسعا امام
تساؤل هل عصر الطفره التقنيه انتهى وبدات
شركات هذا القطاع بالانهيار بعض اسهم
شركات التكنولوجيا فقدت اكثر من 50% من
قيمتها السوقيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
وتكبدت خسائر قاسيه جعلت قيمتها السوقيه
تهوي الى ادنى مستوى خلال سنوات العشره
الماضيه الخسائر هذه دفعت عده شركات
لتسريحي نسب كبيره من موظفيها تجاوزت
المئات في بعض الاحيان وهو ما كان يبدو
امرا مستبعدا قبل سنوات تقرير اتلانتك
الامريكيه قال ان صناعه التكنولوجيا تواجه
ازمه منتصف العمر واشار الى زياده الكبيره
في عمليات التسليح الجماعي والفوضى التي
بدات تتكشف في شركه وتر مؤخرا والانهيار
المستمر للعمله المشفره وكلها امور حدثت
في اوقات متقاربه اضاف موقع اتلانتيك
المدراء التنفيذيين في اكبر شركات التقنيه
يقومون منذ سنوات بتحويل الموارد نحو
مشاريع جديده ذات عوائد غير مؤكده ضرب
الموقع مثلا على شركه امازون التي وظفت
مؤخرا اكثر من 10,000 شخص العملي على منتج
الذكاء الاصطناعي الخاص بها الاكثر يقول
التقرير ان الازمه تتبدى في اهتمام الماسك
بالسيارات والصواريخ اكثر من اهتمامه
بتوتر التي يقبع على راسها الخلاصه بحسب
الموقع ان الفتره الحاليه هي ازمه منتصف
العمر لشركات التكنولوجيا البعضوا
متفائلون بانه قد تكون فتره استراحه بين
العصور الت قد تحدث بعدها طفره في برامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي او ربما يلوح امر اخر في
الافقي قريبا
[موسيقى]
تصريحه قديم كنت انتظر زملائي لكي
يعانقوني لكن لم ياتي احد قلت لهم تعالوا
عانقوني والا فان الحكم لن يحتسب
الهدفنا عن هدفه الشهيره الذي احرزه بيده
في مرمى انجلترا في ربع نهائي المونديال
عام 1986
منه الان الاعتذار غابت شمس صاحب افضل هدف
واغرب هدف
غابت شمس من لعب كره القدم مر بيده لكنه
لعبها دوما بقلبه ومن وراءه احببنا قلنا
ربك كره القدم اما صوره اليوم فيها بدايه
الحكايه من نيبال هنا بين هذه الاقدام
الصغيره تبدا قصه المونديال
المباني
لا يكترثون بخشونه الارض ولا بمرونه
الحذاء ممن لا يهتمون اصلا في وجود حذاء
الكره وكانها كنزهم الوحيد في الحياه بين
هذه الاقدام الصغيره يبدا شغف وهناك في
الدوحه
في كاس العالم طرف واحد يشعر بالقلق اكثر
من الفرحه انه النظام في ايران فبينما
تدور اعجله القمع في الشوارع ضد المحتاجين
يخشى النظام من حركه او سلوك من اللاعبين
قد يحرجه امام العالم
في جناح المنتخب
منتخب
الامور في بلاده الى ما يتمناه الايرانيون
في اشاره لمطالب المحتاجين وسبق للاعبي
المنتخب الايراني ان يرتدوا ازياء الاسود
قبل مباراههم الوديه امام السنغال في
نهايه سبتمبر
في مرمى المنتخب وانما من هدف يسجله
المنتخب في مرمى في مرمى هو
نهايه العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع وتتواصل مع الزميل صهيب شراير صباح
مش صباح ههه
مساء الخير
مساء الخير امم طبعا
المنتخبات العربيه شو رايك يا طاهر همم
ردودنا كلنا ولكن بالاخر بدك تحدد انا
يمكن راح اتفق معك قليلا خلاص ارجنتين
ليونيل ميسي يعني لانه يكرر
شيء من انجاز مارادونا ان شاء الله